welcome to the Tesla crash lab
today we're doing a very special crash
we will be testing a pickup truck
hitting a model y as you see it's a very
small overlap this is what we call an of
Zone impact this is the last piece of
validation for what we believe is a
world first
previously the best way to design a safe
car was four industry standard crash
testing and those crash tests are like a
few grains of sand those grains of sand
are meant to represent the beach but in
reality the beach is infinitely complex
every crash is different with emerging
Technologies there are new opportunities
now we can look at the real world and
design for that
we're the only car maker in the world
that has a fleet of well over a million
cars on the road fully instrumented from
a sensing perspective we can know
exactly where the seat is we can know
where the steering wheel is we know if
they're belted we know when the airbag
deployed exactly to the millisecond we
know exactly what the our Fleet of
course is being exposed to out there The
Riches of data we are collecting enables
us to develop safety beyond the stars
and Beyond the ratings and for
situations which is simply not picked up
by the regulatory rating test that that
we and all other core makers are doing
industry standard crash testing is
focused on impacts directly into the
door we've noticed in the field that
it's very common for your impacts not to
hit the door once we found the Gap in
what the legal testing required and the
types of crashes we saw from our Fleet
data we decided to use our very detailed
simulation models to run impacts in
different locations like this simulation
here
and we use this to really tune down to
the millimeter and down to the mile per
hour the Threshold at which you need
airbags and you don't need airbags we
use that to tune the airbags and the
seat belts for optimal safety
conventional systems don't detect this
type of Crash because it's not an
industry standard this new algorithm
takes into account the current sensor
set interpreted in a new way so that we
can identify this particular type of
Crash and provide the optimum restraint
for that situation
foreign
hundreds of simulations it was time to
test us in the real world
we have 17 high-speed cameras running at
a thousand frames per second and Camera
data forms an integral part of the
information that we collect in a big
test like this in the back of the
vehicle in preparation we have our
instrumentation rack and it's got all
the critical infrastructure to make sure
we get all the data we need so what will
happen is that when this pickup truck
impacts the model y So within 10
milliseconds of impact the system will
have determined what type of impact this
is and then it will trigger the airbag
system and the restrained system to
respond in the best possible way three
two one
foreign
[Applause]
so we just finished the crash test uh
looks like we have a home run result the
course even ended up exactly where we
predicted post crash the detection
worked perfectly and we deployed the
airbags exactly as we intended to as we
wanted to and indeed as we predicted to
and I just had a look at the injury
values recorded by the dummies and they
look beautiful
oh this feels awesome uh this is history
in the making and this is really the end
result of the entire chain of Tesla
strength and safety development starting
up with the field data data analytics
lots of simulation close cooperation
between simulation Engineers design
Engineers coming here to the lab
recreating this whole crash performing
it flawlessly capturing the results now
we have some post-processing to do to
validate everything but once that's done
this is in the pipeline for over the air
updates to the fleet improving the cars
we have more data now than we've ever
had before we can understand real
exposure and then we can design our
vehicles for that exposure
we think over time this will change how
you design for vehicle safety it's all
based on knowledge I think this is just
the beginning of a journey for us the
reasoning we're doing this is simple
it's it's because a we can we have the
ability and B it's because it's the
right thing to do
thank you